[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unbox today we're
taking our first look at amd's new radon
RX 7600 XT which is basically just an RX
7600 with a 16 gab vram buffer so it
probably could have and maybe should
have just been called the RX 7600 16 GB
but I suppose at least it's not an
inferior product with the same name I
the bars set pretty low but we have seen
some pretty dodgy stuff over the years
anyway I'm Keen to see what a 16 GB 7600
has for us but before we find out
today's sponsor spot is brought to you
by Asus and their latest range of z790
motherboards supporting 12th 13th and
14th generation Intel core processors
for those of you seeking a budget
friendly option one of our favorite z790
motherboards is the tough gaming z790
Plus available in either ddr4 or ddr5
variants with and without Wi-Fi there's
also the recently updated version called
the tough gaming z790 Pro featuring ddr5
exclusively but for those of you seeking
something a bit more high-end we've
tested a number of excellent z790 STS
boards and for my personal gaming system
I'm using the r stricks z790 f gaming
Wi-Fi Which packs loads of USB 3 ports
PD 3.13 W charging and a powerful vcor
vrm using 16 90 AMP power stages and
right now for Australian you'll receive
a free Corsair Vengeance RGB 32 GB ddr5
6000 C 36 memory kit when you purchase
select Asus z790 motherboards with an
Asus all-in-one liquid cooler so for
more information please check the link
in the video description okay so as I've
already said the 7600 XT is basically
just a 7600 with twice as much vram and
that's true the only other change though
is a very minor 4% boost to the core
clocks from 2,655 5 MHz to
2755 MHz and this is something you can
manually do on any 7600 so it's hardly a
unique feature of the 7600
XT so like the 7600 the new XT model
packs 248 cores with 128 texture mapping
units and 64 RS there's also 32 RT cores
2 MB of L2 cache and 32 MB of L3 cache
apart from the memory capacity the
memory subsystem is the same so that
means the 7600 XT uses a 128bit wide
memory bus with 18 GBS per second memory
for a bandwidth of 288 GB per second and
what all this means is in order to
double the vram capacity AMD had to go
with a clam shell design like what
Nvidia did with the 16 GB RTX 460 TI
however whereas Nvidia charged a $100
premium for the extra memory AMD is
charging a $60 premium taking the MSRP
from $270 for the r RX 7600 to $330 us
for the 7600 XT so I think a question
potential buyers will ask is is the 7600
XT worth the extra $60 us over the
standard model and I suspect addressing
that question will be very difficult as
measuring the improvements offered by 16
GB of vram can be difficult and for a
few reasons firstly even once you're
able to find a game that exceeds 8 GB of
vram and there are plenty of examples
out there now it's not always obvious
that there's a problem when watching the
frame rate counter most games avoid
performance related issues by simply not
loading the textures that can't be
stored in the graphics memory resulting
in a visual downgrade with stuff like
Blurry looking textures missing details
or bad Popin and for game developers
this is preferable as the Alternatives
which would include stuff like crashing
or unplayable performance they simply
result in an angry customer and you know
most Gamers they're not going to be
blaming a lack of vram still we have
seen examples where performance tanks
and games even crash but this is a less
common occurrence in running out of vram
the point is simply benchmarking an 8 GB
and 16 GB graphics card and looking at
the FPS counter it doesn't tell you the
whole story so be aware of that as we go
over the numbers and if you want a
visual comparison of how 8 GB and 16 GB
memory buffers compare in modern games
then I suggest checking out my 16 GB RTX
46ti review as the rules applied there
also apply here there's not too much
Point redoing all of that testing
because as I said the results apply to
all 8 GB and 16 GB graphics cards now
for testing we're using our ryzen 7
7800x 3D test system with 32 GB of DDR
56000 memory using the latest display
drivers all data has been validated and
updated for this video and in total I've
tested 12 games some with and without
Raad tracing and the resolutions are
Focus for this review will be 10 1080P
and 1440p okay let's take a look at what
we've got first up we have Resident Evil
4 and at 1080p we're looking at a
surprisingly large 16% uplift for the
7600 XT over the standard 7600 making it
just 6% slower than the RTX 460 so
that's a really good Improvement and it
would appear as though the extra vram is
coming in handy here oddly though the
margin is reduced to 9% at 1440p
suggesting that there are other
limitations hitting the na'vi 33 GPU
harder than vram capacity in any case
the 7600 XT is now able to match the RTX
460 with 71 FPS on
average moving on to a plague tail
requim we see that at 1080p the 7600 XT
is just 3% faster than the 7600 so the
difference here purely being that
factory overclock but that does mean
that the 7600 XT is now 11% faster than
the RTX
4060 then when jumping up to 1440p we
see that the 7600 XT is just 2% faster
than the standard model and 6% faster
than the RTX 460 so similar performance
across the board there probably
something to keep an eye on as we go
over all of these results is the 6700 XT
which currently costs
$33 so the same price as the 7600 XT and
here we see that the newer radon GPU is
24% slower so that's certainly not
good next up we have cyber Punk 2077
Phantom Liberty and here we're looking
at a mild 8% uplift for the 7600 XT over
the 7600 making the XT model 6% faster
than the RTX 4060 we're also looking at
a 6% uplift for the 6700 XT at 1440p
making it 8% faster than the RTX 460
though it was also 7% slower than the
6700 XT performance in Dying Light to is
much the same as here we find a mere 2%
uplift when going from the 7600 to the
new XT model and with 96 FPS on average
it matched the RTX 4060 exactly and it's
a similar story at 440p here the 7600 XT
was good for 63 FPS on average which was
one more frame than that of the 7600 But
one less than the RTX 4060 and a lot
less than the 6700 XT in fact it was
177% slower than the previous generation
GPU the performance uplift in Watchdogs
Legion at 1080p is a little better
but not exactly mindblowing we're
getting a 6% boost here though that does
make the 7600 XT 9% faster than the RTX
460 jumping up to 1440p doesn't change
the margins the 7600 XT is still just 6%
faster than the standard 7600 it's also
11% slower than the 6700 XT so that's
quite a disappointing result the 7600 XT
was able to provide an additional 10%
performance in forsa Horizon 5 at 1080p
averaging 114 FPS which meant it was
133% faster than the RTX 460 and just 3%
slower than the 6700 XT and that
additional vram becomes even more useful
at 40 and 40p and now the 7600 XT is
133% faster than the standard 7600 and a
massive 22% faster than the RTX
460 Warhammer 3 isn't a very demanding
title when it comes to vram at least not
by modern standards and as such 8 GB of
vram is more than enough and therefore
the 7600 XT only has its core clock to
fall back on providing a m 3%
performance increase when compared to
the
7600 then at 1440p it's just 2% faster
with 55 FPS on average so basically the
same performance as the RTX
4060 moving on to Spider-Man remastered
we're looking at more of the same here
just a 5% increase for the 7600 XT over
the standard model which means the XT is
133% slower than the RTX 4060 increasing
the resolution to 14 40p actually
reduces the already small margin and now
the XT is offering a mere 3% uplift
though now it is just 6% slower than the
RTX
4060 next up we have Hogwarts Legacy and
again at 1080p the 7600 XT is 5% faster
than the 7600 as well as the RTX
4060 and then jumping up to 1440p it
chose a mere 4% increase though that was
enough to lead the RTX 4060 by double
digits now offering 133% greater
performance Halo infinite is an
interesting title to include in this
video because it's a great example of
how difficult it is to test vram
capacity for example using the ultra
quality preset does require more than 8
GB of vram and yet the 7600 XT is just
2% faster than the
7600 however this game doesn't suffer a
performance hit when played with
insufficient memory rather textures just
go missing and we've shown the
difference between 8 GB and 16 GB gpus
multiple times in the past last the
missing texture problem is even more
noticeable at 1440p but again when're
looking at the frame rate counter you'll
almost see no difference between the
7600 XT and
7600 The Last of Us Part One on the
other hand does suffer a performance hit
when running out of vram at 1080p the
7600 XT is 20% faster than the 7600 and
a massive 58% faster when comparing 1%
lows so the increased varum capacity is
of massive benefit here even at 1080p
then at 1440p the 8 GB cards are a
stuttering mess in the area of the game
we use for testing the 7600 XT solves
this and while the frame rates aren't
amazing suboptimal I'd say the game is
certainly still playable at 47 FPS
finally we have Hitman 3 and here the
7600 XT is offering a decent 10%
performance uplift hitting 142 FPS
opposed to 129 FPS with the standard
7600 that also made it a massive 30%
faster than the rtx4 60 then at 1440p
we're still looking at a 10% Improvement
for the XT over the standard model which
meant it was 28% faster than the RTX
4060 now one downside to adding more vrm
is power usage and we see that here in
Hitman 3 where total system usage was
increased by 16% that means when
compared to the RTX 4060 total system
usage is 33% greater but the 7600 XT was
28% faster in this test so performance
per wat ends up being pretty similar
that said though efficiency is much
worse than a game like Spider-Man
remastered as here the 7600 XT pushed
total system usage 33% higher than that
of the RTX 4060 while delivering 6% less
performance so that's not
great okay so now it's time to go over
the 12 game average data and we'll start
with the 1080p results here the 7600 XT
was on average 8% faster than the
standard 7600 and 6% faster than the RTX
460 so about what you'd probably expect
to see across a range of games then at
1440p the 7600 XT was just 5% faster
than the 7600 When comparing the average
frame rate but a much more substantial
19% margin can be seen when comparing 1%
lows so that's an impressive set of
results for the 7600 XT though it was
also 12% slower than the 6700 XT now
although I didn't bother going over the
4K data as this isn't really a 4K GPU I
do have the data so let's take a quick
look at the 12 average here the 7600 XT
was 9% faster on average and 25% faster
when comparing 1% lows it also blew the
RTX 460 out of the water increasing the
average frame rate by
23% next we're going to take a look at R
tracing performance and we'll start with
Resident Evil 4 using the r tracing
quality preset at 1080p the 7600 XT was
really no faster than the 7600 making it
18% slower than the RTX 460 which is a
disappointing result result a plag toil
recm though kills at GB gpus when using
the ultra quality preset with r tracing
enabled the 7600 is completely unusable
and the RTX 460 is really no better the
4060 TI 8 GB looks okay based on the 41
FPS average frame rate but the 1% lows
reveal just how poor the experience is
the fact that the 1% lows of the 7600 XT
are 56% greater as one thing but it's
the discrepancy between the 1% lows and
the average frame rate that really tell
the story for example there's a 43%
margin between the 1% lows and the
average frame rate for the 7600 XT but a
128% difference for the 8 GB 460 TI
still the 7600 XT is pretty slow here so
you will have to use upscaling which
frankly sucks in terms of visual quality
at 1080p doesn't really matter if it's
FSR or dlss all upscaling techniques are
pretty bad at 1080p so you would
probably be better off just disabling R
tracing all together at which point the
8 GB models are perfectly
fine now cyberpunk 2077 Phantom Liberty
has been tested using the r tracing
medium preset at 1080P and despite that
frame rates are very low on these more
entry level gpus even the RTX 4060 was
good for just 38 FPS on average and
again using dlss to boost performance
isn't an optimal solution given how poor
upscaling quality is at 1080P and
likewise frame generation also doesn't
work very well when the Basse frame rate
is just 38 FPS so there's no good fix
for this the 7600 XT was 17% faster than
the 7600 But also 26% slow on the RTX
460 so while rate tracing support on the
GeForce GP is questionable here it's
completely useless on the Radeon
gpus Spider-Man remastered has been
tested using the highquality preset with
high quality R tracing and at 1080p the
performance is excellent the 7600 XT
spat out at 104 FPS on average which is
great though it's really no better than
the standard 7600 this also meant that
it was 17% slower than the RTX
460 the 7600 XT fell just short of 60
FPS in Star Wars Jedi Survivor using
rate tracing with the Epic quality
preset making it just 5% slower than the
RTX 4060 it was also 10% faster than the
standard 7600 But also 11% slower than
the 6700
XT finally we have for and the Epic
quality settings with Hardware rate
tracing enabled is a bit too much for
the 7600 XT as it was good for just 35
FPS on average a 9% increase from the
7600 But 20% slower than the RTX
4060 okay so across the six games tested
the 7600 XT was on average 30% faster
than the standard 7600 or a massive 64%
faster when comparing the 1% lows so
that's a serious performance uplift
there by simply doubling the vram but of
course of course as we saw in examples
such as a plague toil requium that was
the difference between playable and
completely unplayable performance still
despite having just 8 GB of vram the
GeForce RTX 4060 was faster overall
delivering 133% greater performance on
average though the 1% lows were much the
same also something worth noting is the
fact that the Arc
a770 was as fast or typically faster
than the 7600 XT across these R Racing
titles making it not just more
affordable but also better for R
tracing now it's time to check out the
cost per Frame data and of course we
will start with an MSRP comparison sadly
with an extra $60 us tacked onto the
price the 7600 XT is much worse value
than the original 7600 increasing the
cost per frame based on our 1440p data
by
177% that said though the added benefit
of doubling the vram it's not always
realized in these benchmarks as I noted
in Halo infinite for example so the fact
that the 7600 XT and RTX 460 represent
similar value in terms of cost per frame
in games like Halo the 7600 XT can
enable a much higher visual experience
simply because it can load all required
textures moreover if you want 16 GB from
the current Nvidia lineup you have to
buy the RTX 4060 ti6 gab which is only
20% faster than the 7600 XT despite
costing nearly 40 % more and that's at
the new $450 us
MSRP anyway msrps don't always reflect
real world pricing so let's take a look
at the current retail
prices right so in the current market
the 7600 XT doesn't look great and
that's because for roughly the same
money you can buy the 6700 XT which
still packs 12 GB of vram but was an
average 133% faster and perhaps worse
still is the RX 6800 which is a 16 GB
graphics card
and although it currently costs 27% more
it's also 42% faster and much more
usable in situations where you want to
enable Ray tracing there's also Intel's
AR a770 Which packs 16 GB of vram for
just $300 making it better value than
the 7600
XT now before wrapping things up let's
quickly take a look at some custom board
partner designs and please note there
isn't a reference model version of the
7600 XT the model I use for testing is
Sapphire's pulse a reasonably compact
dual fan model that's powered by dual 8
Pin PCI power connectors though sadly it
doesn't support dual bars functionality
for testing it was installed inside an
ATX case with a room temperature of 21°
and was placed under gaming load for an
hour after an hour The Junction
temperature picked at 69° with a GPU
Hotpot temperature of 87° and this was
achieved with a fan speed of just 1300
RPM so a very impressive result the
memory also peaked at 86° which is
acceptable and clocked at
2,238 MHz with the cores typically
operating at
2,595
MHz also on hand for testing is the XFX
Speedster quick 309 7600 XT which is a
much larger higher end looking model but
also the quick 308 RX 7600 is an MSRP
model available for $270 us so it's
quite possible that the quick 309 will
also be MSRP model selling for $330 us
and if so it's a very impressive model
for that price packing dual bar support
a triple fan cooler massive heat sink
and a full aluminium back plate and
performance-wise it's very good The
Junction temperature peaked at 62° and
the hot spot hit 83° so both slightly
less than that of the sapphire pulse
though the fan speed was also slightly
higher at 1600 RPM we also saw a similar
memory temperature at 85° with the big
difference here being the operating
clock speed as the cor is typically
clocked at
2750 MHz and that's 6% higher than that
of the sapphire model so a good result
there for
XFX then finally we have the gigabyte
gaming OC 7600 XT and these gaming OC
models have been a bit hit and miss
lately this 7600 XT version for example
it does look quite good it's a
relatively large model with a triple fan
cooler the heat sink is very big and it
includes a full-size aluminium back
playay
sadly though it was quite loud with a
fan speed of 2,000 RPM and despite that
the operating temperatures weren't
amazing sure the junction temperature
56° was good but the GPU Hotpot still
hit 84° a degree higher than that of the
XFX model the memory temperatures though
they were pretty good peaking at
78° and that's a 7° improvement from the
speeds to Qui 309 so overall it is a
decent product but without dual bias
support for something like a silent bias
it's not the most optimal out-of thebox
experience and temperatures will likely
suffer when turning the fan speed down
from 2,000 RPM to something more
suitable like 1600 or even 1300
RPM okay so there you have it amd's new
radon RX 7600 XT we've just looked at a
hi benchmarks what do we actually make
of this thing I think it's fair to say
that evaluating a product like this is a
bit difficult because the cost per Frame
data doesn't necessarily tell the full
story and that's because
the frame rate uh it's not always an
Apples to Apples comparison like what we
see in Halo infinite for example
although two cards can be producing
similar FPS numbers the resulting image
quality can be quite difficult so yeah
not Apples to Apples data and we
absolutely hate that unfortunately
because of the way most games handle
insufficient vram you have to carefully
analyze stuff like image quality but
even then it can be difficult as many
games will require you to play them for
extended periods of time in in order to
fill the vram buffer Halo for example
can take 15 to 30 minutes before the 8
GB cards run into trouble and when they
do the FPS counter it's none the wiser
rather you'll notice blurry textures and
missing details without question though
16 GB of vram is much better than eight
but also the navi 33 GPU it's not super
powerful so you're less likely to be
running at resolutions and quality
settings that will saturate an 8 GB
buffer though of course you still can
and it certainly does happen but how
often will depend on the games you play
there's also the future games angle how
well is an 8 GB 7600 going to age over
the next few years when compared to the
7600 XT probably not that well despite
the fact that these are lower in gpus
and as an example the 8 GB version of
the RX 580 Works significantly better
than the 4 GB model using medium to
lowquality settings in modern games and
in fact you can turn the textures up for
a much higher quality presentation ation
so naturally we can't expect the same
thing to happen with 8 GB versus 16 GB
graphics cards and we'll probably see
that come to light over the next few
years of course we already are seeing
examples of this but I expect it to be
much more common place in the near
future I think a $60 us premium for an
extra 8 GB of vram is decent but the
problem for me is just the starting
price when I reviewed the RX 7600 about
8 months ago now I said it really needed
to cost no more than $230 us and I stand
firmly behind that claim my Hope was
that the 16 GB version would step in and
match the price of the RTX 4060
essentially eliminating the GeForce
competition at that price point but at
$330 us it's rather an expensive entry
level GPU and the argument could be made
that the 6700 XT for around $340 us
right now is a better deal it also
doesn't shut down the RTX 460 which will
remain a viable option delivering
similar performance and value with
generally better Raad tracing
performance though I do question how
useful RT support is at this performance
tier there's also the arc a770 16 GB for
$300 which is a seriously good deal
though it might come with a few
headaches as we're yet to test an AR GPU
and a reasonable range of games and not
have it run into at least one annoying
problem but things are certainly getting
better on that front at the end of the
day the 7600 XT is another frustrating
release from AMD as they once again just
managed to miss the Mark had they
released this thing at $300 us it would
have matched the value of the 6700 XT
coming in a little bit slower but also a
bit cheaper with a bit more vram it
would have eliminated the RTX 4060 and
while it might have done the same to the
$270 RX 7600 they could have either
discounted or discontinued that product
really what AMD should have done here
was release the RX 7600 at $300 8 months
ago but with 16 gabt of memory I mean
ideally I would have wanted that product
at $270 but given what we ended up
getting I think a 16 GB model for $300 8
months ago would have been a much better
option for everyone well everyone but
Nvidia so while it is nice to have more
options and I really do prefer the 16 GB
7600 XT to that of the 8 GB 7600 think
it's going to be a much better
investment this particular product it's
also not necessarily a product that I
would hire High recommend and it's
certainly still a tossup between
something like this and the RTX 4060
which is a bit of a shame because AMD
really could have shut the door on
Nvidia at this price point so with that
let me know what you think about the
7600 XT in the comments section below
and of course I will be reading your
feedback and taking that on board for
future evaluations for now we are done
with this one if you liked the video you
know what to do subscribe for more
content because believe it or not we
have more new GPU content coming up on
the channel very short shortly so you're
not going to want to miss that also we
have float plane patreon if you want
more hard R box goodness signing up to
either one of those things will give you
access to exclusive Discord server
monthly live streams Q&A behind the
scenes content lot of cool stuff there
so check that out if you're interested
but if not that's perfectly fine and of
course I would like to just thank you
for watching this video if you made it
this far then yeah we uh really do
appreciate you so good job there but
yeah nothing else to say really other
than I'm your host Steve and I will see
you again next
time
[Music]